so once again thank you very much for
being with us I hope you understand that
none of the circus that's been going on
has been on our by coming from us
another common sista
we understand that you spoke with some
detectives at the hospital and
fortunately they weren't handling the
case they just were the division that
was right there in the area so they we
were come from back down they were from
right there they showed up there helping
us out and so they do formal interview
they basically took notes after we could
after you had left yeah so that's why
Warren turn those off nine lives yeah I
mean we took very few notes but they
knew that they weren't handling it so
they thought that we were going to talk
oh so um how long have you been dr. Kerr
distressed 2006 and knows continuous
2006 on no well no or are not open on
intermittent okay do you know if he was
under the care of any other doctors she
never disclose that to me but because he
moved around so much I would assume that
he wants people so you're not sure if
you're the only doctor no I'm sorry
doctor okay doctor are you I am caveated
interventional cardiologist and my
subspecialty I am a cardiologist as a
specialist I have a specialty also in
the tournament
Oh 3 did the Jackson specifically
Michael seek you out for that reason
because you're a cardiologist or no I
first met him in 2006 when a patient
friend was the security guard with him
ass so did I see him as a request
because he would not even well you
wanted to see a doctor yes I
and when you first started attending
seeing Michael Jackson 2006 what was
that for there was the family flew
illness between himself and his children
they were coughing and runny nose and
they felt dehydrated and they were not
really getting enough rest about
and I'm sorry you are referred by a
patient of yours the patient's son who
who also is a patient of my practice and
heedless of security you're the security
guard and he made the recommendation
there's a last section of time that
you've been caring for him how how long
continuously has it been a little over
two months he tell us how that came to
be
I was called by miss Jackson assistant
his name is Amir Amir brother me and he
said Miss Jessie wanted to speak to me
and then he mentioned that that the
first time I'd seen him for a while that
they were going to be doing the concert
tours in England this is Jackson very
much alike me to be part of the trip and
to be there for this concept and when i
read that and said well I need more
details about nights and there was a
gross basically just the question then
he cordons to Jackson the party ever
present and probably after hours so I
got a call from the suggestion tell me
how elated he was that I would want to
join the trip of course it and I'll have
I'm sure if you guys have heard on the
news the news is reporting that you
don't work for mr. Jackson but you work
for AEG is that correct or incorrect how
do i define that what mr. Jackson asked
me to be on this team I was talking to
mr. Dyson itself he offered me
employment and I was on the opinion that
he would be my employer directly
subsequently to accepting that high
record i realized that AEG would be the
one paying for the salary that he
requested so that was the arrangements
as far so it would finance me on so I am
an employee for Michael Jackson but paid
through a
oh yes so Michael pics you but somebody
else to get the 10